an area that covers almost 160,000
square kilometers in South America it is
known as the eso which since 2015 has
been found to be rich in natural
resources it is controlled by Guyana but
claimed by Venezuela on Tuesday
Venezuelan president Nikolas Maduro said
he will authorize oil exploration in an
area close to the eso River and create a
new state known as
Guana we immediately proceed to create
the division
ESO and seibo and immediately we'll
proceed to give operating licenses for
the exploration exploitation of oil gas
and mines in all our Guyana esba the
announcement followed a weekend
referendum in which Venezuelans voted to
claim sovereignty over the region the
international criminal court barred
Venezuela from taking any action that
changes the status quo in the all rich
area and the Guan president Iran Ali
says he has asked the United States and
the UN for help Ali told Al jazer that
Venezuela is threatening his country's
territorial Integrity sovereignty and
political
Independence we would like the United
Nations security Council to issue a very
strong statement to Venezuela in
relation to the to to Venezuela
breaching the order of the
icj and order that can be enforceable
and we would like to see the full
commitment of United Nations security
Council to ensure that they do
everything to to to to have this region
remains a region of peace and stability
the dispute goes back to Colonial times
between Spain the Netherlands and the
United Kingdom Guyana gained
independence in 1966 and the argument
has been ongoing the Venezuelan
opposition says Maduro is using the eso
conflict to hold on to
power we have to find a specific way out
of this and it will in the international
criminal court to escalate abello's
rhetoric to escape the electoral process
in Venezuela because they know they will
lose something that neither Venezuelans
or the International Community will
tolerate it is a decades long
territorial dispute but the possibility
of extracting natural resources here has
emboldened Venezuela and put its smaller
neighbor on edge there is Al